Let's begin by creating a
data frame called emails
using the read.csv function.
And loading up energy_bids.csv.
And as always, in the
text analytics week,
we're going to pass
stringsAsFactors=FALSE to this
function.
So we can take a look at the
structure of our new data frame
using the str function.
We can see that there
are 855 observations.
This means we have 855 labeled
emails in the data set.
And for each one we have
the text of the email
and whether or not it's
responsive to our query
about energy schedules and bids.
So let's take a look at a few
example emails in the data set,
starting with the first one.
So the first email can be
accessed with emails$emailemails$email[1].
Almost like the first one.
So while the output you
get when you type this
will depend on what operating
system you're running on,
many of you will see
what I'm displaying here.
Which is a single
line of text that we
need to horizontally
scroll to read through.
This is a pretty tough way
to read a long piece of text.
So if you have this
sort of display,
you can use the strwrap function
and pass it the long string you
want to print out, in
this case emails$email.
Selecting the first one.
And now we can see that this
has broken down our long string
into multiple shorter lines
that are much easier to read.
OK.
So let's take a look
now at this email,
now that it's a
lot easier to read.
We can see just by parsing
through the first couple
of lines that this
is an email that's
talking about a
new working paper,
"The Environmental
Challenges and Opportunities
in the Evolving North
American Electricity Market"
is the name of the paper.
And it's being released
by the Commission
for Environmental
Cooperation, or CEC.
So while this certainly deals
with electricity markets,
it doesn't have to do with
energy schedules or bids.
So it is not responsive
to our query.
So we can take a look at
the value in the responsive
variable for this email using
email$responsive and selecting
the first one.
And we have value 0 there.
So let's take a look at the
second email in our data set.
Again I'm going to use
the strwrap function.
I'm going to pass
it emails$emailemails$email[1].
And scrolling up
the top here we can
see that the original message
is actually very short,
it just says FYI,
for your information.
And most of it is a
forwarded message.
So we have all the
people who originally
received the message.
And then down at the very
bottom is the message itself.
"Attached is my report prepared
on behalf of the California
State auditor."
And there's an attached
report, ca report new.pdf.
Now our data set contains
just the text of the emails
and not the text
of the attachments.
But it turns out,
as we might expect,
that this attachment had to do
with Enron's electricity bids
in California.
And therefore it is
responsive to our query.
And we can check this in
the responsive variable.
emails$responsive[2].
And we see that that's a 1.
So now let's look
at the breakdown
of the number of emails that are
responsive to our query using
the table function.
We're going to pass
it emails$responsive.
And as we can see the
data set is unbalanced,
with a relatively small
proportion of emails responsive
to the query.
And this is typical in
predictive coding problems.